lected Harry and I do that night under
the covers do I think Nicole deserves
getting money at the end
did anyone flirt or hook up with the
crew so you guys I'm pretty was it gonna
get so much T hi I'm Francesca from too
hot to handle and today I'm gonna be
answering some of your burning questions
what was I told the plot of the show was
going to be when I was auditioning so I
wasn't really told anything about the
plot all I knew was that I had to be
single I had to like the beach because I
knew it was gonna be film somewhere
tropical and that was basically it so I
went into it super super blind
I was actually reached out by one of the
production members via Instagram DM so I
didn't even audition so it was very
quick like I had my first audition via
Skype call and then I was in Mexico a
few weeks later so I really didn't know
what we were there for until obviously
you guys saw that big reveal from Alana
so that was literally I didn't know that
there was gonna be money involved until
we were signing contracts right before
we got onto filming that indicated some
sort of prize but until like I was in
Mexico I had no idea that there was
gonna be money involved what was the
audition process for too hot to handle
so I'm not exactly sure because I didn't
audition but the process to get on it
after I was reached out to basically was
I had a Skype call with a few members of
the production and then I had a Skype
call with the main producer so basically
when we were chatting they wanted me to
like be flirty they I make ask me to get
up and like dance around a little bit so
that was kind of awkward they played
some music and wanted me to dance they
asked a lot about my sex life which I
thought was weird now obviously it makes
sense why they were asking that they
asked a lot about my past relationships
craziest first dates like how often I
get DM stuff like that it was very like
sexual relationship orientated questions
so that's kind of why it gave me an idea
that it was maybe like a weird twist on
a dating show I think every single cast
member was there for the right reason
and everyone was like very horny very
not really into having long-term
relationship so we were each put there
first did anyone get away with secretly
masturbating or hooking up I'm not sure
about the masturbation
um because there was mics literally
everywhere like when Harry and I told
each other that we loved each other we
said that very very quietly like we
wanted it to be kind of a private moment
which we shouldn't have had made it so
private but we wanted it to be just
between us and it was heard so I don't
think anyone could have gotten away with
anything because there was mics the
strongest just mics ever everywhere like
there's mics hanging from the ceilings
there is mics hidden behind doors like
you really couldn't get away with
anything so from my knowledge so like I
don't think anything what was the
packing list that production told us to
bring so basically we were just told to
bring a lot of bikinis we had to take
photos of outfits that we're gonna wear
prior so they wanted to confirm stuff to
bring no labels nothing like that and
everything we knew was basically gonna
be supplied for us so they were like
everything you ever need is gonna be
there for you and it was actually true
like they had sunscreen they had hair
straighteners that makeup brushes all
this stuff we had a nail person come in
to do our nails we had a barber come in
to cut the guy's hair so all we needed
was outfits and I was actually allowed
to bring three suitcases so I had like
one suitcase of shoes and one suitcase
bikinis and one of outfits for like
daytime and nighttime yeah we literally
got dressed up every single day so every
single outfit was used how many days
total worry in the hot too hot to handle
retreat so we were there give or take a
total of 2025 days we were filming for
an entire month so we flew to Mexico we
had like 4 days in isolation so I was
allowed my phone
but I wasn't allowed to leave the hotel
room so it was like kind of weird I was
just like stuck in this hotel room like
anticipation waiting to go on the
retreat and then when we were there it
was a full month of filming so a full
month no cell phone a full months no
talking to our friends a full month no
talking to my mom it was very hard but
they really wanted us to immerse
ourselves in the experience so by the
end of the month like it was like
getting our phones back was very weird
they get felt weird being in the normal
world laughter what were the black belts
that we were wearing and did we have to
wear them so those were microphones you
think there would be like a smaller
Micra could have worn cuz it didn't go
with any of my outfit ruined a lot of
outfits I had to keep changing what I
was
we're because I had this cute dress but
the little black thing didn't work with
it so yeah it was a mic that went around
our neck and then the mic pack attached
behind in her back and it was waterproof
so we've go swimming with in stuff like
that it was basically just like the
microphone that would catch everything
and sometimes I thought I was whispering
talking so quietly but they could hear
everything like that's how strong those
mics were if we so we were allowed to
take the mics off to sleep and we were
allowed to take the mics off to shower
but while we were sleeping and while we
while we were showering the mics had to
be right outside the shower or right
beside our bed and if we started to get
ready or we started to walk around the
retreat without the mics on production
would sprint after us the big picture my
god like we always always always always
had to add a mic on and we actually
we're allowed to take our mics off when
we're eating because that's when the
battery packs would be changed but the
table we were eating at was like there's
mics all over it so we literally
couldn't get away with talking about
anything why did I continue to pursue
Harry after he lied about the kiss to
the group while we were there what I was
seeing was a little bit different that
was kind of going on like from my
perspective or the only thing I saw
Harry lying about was when the group
reveal happened so when Lana told
everyone about the kiss so that's what I
was saying I didn't necessarily see him
and Rhonda talking did about me in bed I
didn't see the group chat with the boys
in the bedroom that you guys all saw so
that made it a little bit easier to
forgive him I didn't know any of this
was happening but he did apologize um he
did make amends like after we got back
together he was such an amazing
boyfriend like he would always hide
snacks under my pillows like make sure I
always had a clean towel like help me
with my outfits like he was just very
supportive so he was a little at the
beginning and honestly so was i but I
think I thought we just both got over it
and like grew stronger Hayley was the
only person who stood it up for me about
the case so why wasn't I upset when she
was asked to leave and do I think she
was portrayed fairly so okay I was very
upset there was a scene where I was
crying about my my leg comparing it to
my mom passing away I was talking about
Hayley and I was
like you can kind of see blips of me
crying and being really upset they
didn't show of course everyone saw they
didn't show much about her leaving that
night but it was a really hard night for
me and I was very very upset because I
lost like my confidante I lost my
partner in crime and it was really sad
but it did allow me to go deeper into my
relationship with Harry her not being
there so that was the only plus of that
but everything that was portrayed of her
she did say those things but her good
qualities and everything that's amazing
about her that I loved so much wasn't
Joan so everything that was portrayed
about her it was true but she also has
this amazing genuine sweet caring side
of her that wasn't portrayed so I think
she's an amazing person and I think
she's just hilarious and she says it how
it is and some people don't like that
but I thought it was amazing so did
anyone flirt or hook up with the crew so
we had a very attractive crew and it was
I remember the first day we were doing
the very first b-roll when we talked
about the very intro of the show and we
talked about ourselves and I was nervous
because the cameramen were very
attractive like they were hot honestly
they were so hot but no like I think
there was a little flirting but it was
more just like we are confined there was
only ten of us we were trying to like
have a good time and everyone on the
crew was very very nice and they're all
married so there was no hanky-panky what
did Harry and I do that night under the
covers and did anyone hear me so after
that happened
Chloe actually came up and was like you
know
okay like she asked if we're okay and we
were just giggling so hard cuz we
thought we got away with it like we were
just kind of being as sneaky as we could
like we thought obviously we were being
very sneaky and we just weren't like
because those mics are so strong and we
didn't necessarily realize how powerful
they were like you pretty here like
everything that was happening so yeah I
mean obviously the whole group ended up
finding out about it anyways which was
kind of embarrassing but yeah living
Chloe no no one noticed
why didn't I defend myself to Chloe
after she confronted me about the date
with Cory so honestly I'm not a
confrontational person whatsoever and I
think that's why everyone was calling
Haley my puppet master
says she speaks up and I don't speak up
this is how I am in every aspect of my
life I'm not a confrontational person
when someone puts me into a corner I
just kind of freeze and I guess that's
what happened and I was just like I
didn't really understand why she was
upset I was like it has nothing to do
with you like I didn't really have time
to even ask you if it was okay for me to
do it I got asked and then I went and I
was honestly just like tired I just
washed my makeup off she still had a
full face of glam on and I was like I'm
not trying to talk to you right now like
I just really wasn't in the mood and it
sounds like super plain mean of me to
say I just wasn't having it and I was
like there's nothing I can say to change
your mind like you're done with me so
that's fine like we'll make up
eventually but yeah I'm gonna go to bed
why do I think that the group spent time
embracing Rhonda and Shawn's
relationship and judging mine and
Harry's so I think that because Harry
and I were the first to lose money
we were automatically put in this
category oh we can't trust them and
because blame was put on me I was just
seen as the villain as well as because
of the kiss with Haley that
automatically put mine and Harry's
relationship to like the level of people
didn't like it and especially like the
Carroll situation like I was putting
myself out there in a lot of situations
and I did to date with Corey the date
with cows I kissed Haley I broke rules
with Harry and that's a lot of things
for people to not like especially on the
show like it was a lot of reasons for
them not to like me but they just didn't
really understand why I was doing any of
this and I don't know I feel like maybe
it could have stemmed from jealousy
because no one else was really forming a
relationship Rhonda and Sheroes
relationship did seem like so perfect
but I mean no relationship is perfect
and I me and Harry are still together
now so we proved everyone wrong
Madison and Cole barely had any screen
time throughout the series what were
they like on the retreat spell 70 Nicole
was she was a great person she kind of
just didn't really do much as you could
kind of see on the show she kind of was
more reserved she didn't explore any
relationships really she kind of was
just having no vacation and doing her
own thing and
enjoying her time but she wasn't really
putting herself out there I feel like
from me I would really put myself out
there and I did crazy things cuz I
wanted to immerse myself in the
experience and I feel like she just
wasn't doing that so it's not like she
was cropped out I just don't think there
was a lot of scenes that she was in it's
like the only way to describe it and for
Madison she didn't want to put herself
out there either she came in and I just
told her I was like can you want to ask
Carrie on a date if you want to ask
anyone on a date you should do that
you're only here for a few days like you
might as well take advantage of the
situation and she just didn't want to
she was just like man like chilling so I
feel like that's why both of them were
cut out so much because they just really
didn't have like a storyline do I think
Nicole deserves getting money at the end
I do believe that everyone had a part in
people's experiences so there was a lot
of people that did deserve the money I'm
just gonna be honest and say I don't
think she developed as a person as much
as a lot of us did but then again a lot
of people could say I didn't just third
the money either because I lost a lot of
it even though I want it back yeah
there's definitely people who didn't
Merce themselves as much and put
themselves out there as much so I don't
think the money was split and
necessarily fairly of course I wanted
just Harry and I to win it but watching
me show back do I think I was portrayed
fairly I definitely think everyone's
highest highs were portrayed in their
lowest lows were portrayed so there were
some things that I said that I did say
of course and I wish weren't shown I
swore a lot and I was kind of mean to
some other people and stuff like that
honestly I'm just gonna be honest I
thought that I was gonna be portrayed as
the villain to the entire world I was
preparing over the past year for
everyone not to like me because people
on the retreat didn't like me so I was
like okay if ten people don't like me
then the entire world's definitely not
gonna like me so that part was scary but
I think they portrayed me as I as I
really am so I think the fans and the
audience who watched it were able to
relate to me a little more because I was
so honest and I was myself so I do enjoy
the way I was portrayed like there's
obviously some cringe moments that I
said that I wish weren't portrayed but
I'm overall like happy with the way that
everything care though
her better for ways to anyone
an edit on-screen that was different
from their real life persona Haley was
portrayed more negatively she is a very
positive person and none of that was
shown so for her that I think that
that's definitely the case was I
offended by anyone's diary sessions when
I watched the show back so not really um
I was expecting it to be a lot worse I
think they didn't show people talking as
much trash about me as they were so I'm
happy with it like I expected a lot
worse from the diary room like I talked
a lot of I know everyone else talked a
lot of and they made it very like
light-hearted and I think that there was
a lot of positivity that came out from
the show did anything happen in the
retreat that didn't make it to the final
cut so the one thing that I was hoping
to see was when Harry asked me to be his
girlfriend was the night that we lost
the $20,000 but I think we were natured
when that happen so that I think that's
the only thing because obviously they
can't air it if we're naked when he was
asking the bees girlfriend so that I
wish made it but then again I'm like
okay like if we didn't have clothes on
probably a good thing that we heard that
Nicole and Bryce are dating since
filming did I see any chemistry between
them on the show I didn't see any
chemistry between them but I loved Bryce
I support price whatever he wants to do
and I'm happy if he's happy I guess
we'll just have to wait and see where
this relationship goes it you know takes
off if it's real we don't know so we'll
just have to wait and see but I'm happy
for Bryce
because I love him so much so I'm glad
he found someone and I wish the best
nothing for Nicole no no David is such a
fan favorite why do I think he didn't
end up with anyone on the show David's
an amazing guy but you put 10 people in
a house not all of them are gonna have
the chemistry that Harry and I have I
think he tried with Chloe
I think him a Nicole chatted a bit he
tried with Lydia as well which is there
wasn't that spark there unfortunately he
didn't find the love that Harry and I
have but I know for sure after this
comes out like the shock comes out he
will because he's a babe and he's got
everything going for him so if you
didn't find love since the show he's
definitely to find it now if I could do
the process all over again would I
change anything I think
the only thing I would change would be
getting caught cuz that's a and maybe I
would have been a little bit less flirty
with Cal's and Cory cuz that was really
hard to watch back like I didn't even
realize how flirty I was being I'm just
a really quick flirty person and I
didn't even realize it until watching
that and I would also maybe just take
away the downunder
part when I lost 6k cuz that was just
like I feel so bad from Earth here it's
having to watch that I'm like sorry that
didn't need to happen you know like I
could have avoided that but everything
else no I don't regret anything and I
wouldn't change a thing because it led
me to where I am now today with my
relationship sorry do I keep in touch
with anyone from the cast so I talked to
Haley of course every day I talked to
Harry a hundred times a day
Chloe and Nicole and I remained close I
loved Bryce and him and I kept kept a
great relationship as well other than
that we have a group chat we all talk
usually daily we support one another or
each other's Heitmann ends but I didn't
really stay close with anyone else
a lot of do to respect for Harry of
course it wouldn't be fair to him if I
maintained a relationship with cows Ark
or anything like that so why did Harry
and I break up for a few months after
filming and how did we end up getting
back together so there was a lot going
on and him being in Australia and me
being in Canada it was really hard to
maintain that long distance especially
after we had a month together 24/7
joined-at-the-hip and then he flew to
see me two weeks later and then I flew
to see him two weeks later so we were
literally not apart for like three
months so when we separated and when I
got back home and he wasn't moving or
going to LA until like later that year
it was just really hard and we were both
being very immature and honestly when we
spoke about it when we got back together
we like why do we break up and we really
didn't even know it was kind of just
over a stupid argument like we didn't
see eye to eye on a few things and we
just cut it off but deep down I knew
after the breakup that we were always
always gonna get back together so I was
just a matter of time I wasn't gonna
reach out first and he was the one who
reached out first he got his friends to
send me messages on Instagram and then
he drunkenly texting me asking to
FaceTime my dog because I just got a new
puppy so
like oh he want to FaceTime my dog fine
so that's just like I would start it and
right when we hung out again for the
first time after the break it was like
magic all over again and it was like we
never even split up if I could choose
one reality show to be on next what
would it be
honestly I don't know if I would ever do
another reality show unless it was with
Harry so I'm not sure there was like a
couple happy ending reality show that
him and I could do together maybe like a
home improvement show like something
really wholesome I don't know you never
know because I think I reached my cap
book I experienced so much on that show
and I've learned so much about myself so
doing it a second time just wouldn't be
the same thank you so much for all the
questions I really appreciate it and
make sure you stream to how to handle on
Netflix
[Music]